if the area of each circle is 9 pi what  is the area of the Shaded part we'll get  started by setting pi r squared equal to  9 pi so then r squared is equal to 9 and  R is equal to 3.  to find out the dimensions of the  quadrilateral we'll construct the  following line through the tangent  points and the centers of the circles  and this is equal to a length of 4r  now of course the other side is also  equal to 4r in length so we have a  square that's 4r by 4r and that means  its area is equal to 4r the quantity  squared which is equal to 12 squared and  that's equal to 144. we then want to  subtract out 4 times the area of a  single Circle but we know the area of a  single circle is equal to 9 pi so the  area of the Shaded part is equal to 144  minus 36 pi